[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous 100e édition de la saison
pour le 7-8 journal sur tv soixante dix
huit le tour d'horizon de l'actualité
locale et régionale
tout de suite les titres de ce jeudi à 8
mars c'est la journée internationale des
droits des femmes moment de
sensibilisation sur l'égalité femmes
hommes 1 mais aussi de mémoire des
luttes féministes et d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui des événements programmés
à cette occasion nous serons au prisme
est elle en cours qui organise une table
ronde ce soir score sportif au féminin
et nous ferons le point dans ce journal
sur les travaux d'extension entamé
depuis un an à vélizy 2 débuts dès 2019
le centre commercial yvelinois aura un
nouvel espace est dédié à la
restauration et un cinéma flambant neuf
objectif affiché augmenter le nombre de
visiteurs
et puis le printemps des poètes se
poursuit à saint quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui jeudi les poèmes et récits
ont été déclamés à bord des véhicules
ski bus c'est la troisième année
consécutive que cette action est menée
deux invités également à suivre dans ce
journal xavier laroche membres du
conseil national des scouts unitaires de
france pour parler notamment de
l'implantation du scoutisme dans les
yvelines à nous recevrons également et
vanessa van cutsem des colibris de
versailles elle nous sommes à un mois de
la deuxième édition de cet événement
impulsée par à l'association c'est le
festival de cinéma des alternatives
c'est à suivre dans ce journal
la journée internationale des droits des
femmes c'est aujourd'hui c'est
l'occasion notamment de faire le point
sur la violence faite aux femmes la
lutte contre cette violence qui est
devenu une grande cause régionale en
2017 l'île de france s'est dotée
d'outils pour faire progresser cette
lutte
un an après quel est le bilan en ile de
france un sujet devient grand paris en
ile de france plus d'une femme sur 10
est victime de violences conjugales
un chiffre supérieur à la moyenne
nationale
parmi ces femmes francilienne une sur
cinq à moins de 25 ans en 2016 c'est
plus de 12 mille cent cinquante de faits
de violences commis au sein du couple
qui ont été enregistrées par la police
de paris et de la petite cour
une brutalité qui se retrouvent dans le
cadre scolaire
une jeune sur trois déclarent avoir subi
des violences sexuelles en 2016 la
région ile de france avait fait de la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes sa grande cause régionale en 2017
est la mise en place tout un panel
d'outils pour prévenir et protéger les
femmes par exemple les logements mis à
disposition des femmes victimes ont été
doublées des campagnes de
sensibilisation ont aussi été lancées
faut aussi que les jeunes filles
puissent avoir en tête qu'elles peuvent
dire loup et ça se prépare très tôt et
on a fait de belles campagnes notamment
celles qui me vient en tête c'est le je
t'aime
si tu m'aimes tu peux tu me respectes ne
prend pas justement pour pour
sensibiliser les jeunes je crois que
dans les lycées en ile de france nous
avons la compétence des 10 et c'est 500
lycées ou où on a fait ce travail là
pour protéger les femmes dans les
transports un numéro d' alerte vient
d'être mise en place
le 31 17 en ile de france six femmes sur
dix ont peur dans les transports en
commun c'est un passage obligatoire dans
la vie du jeune français une journée à
défense et citoyenneté se tenait
aujourd'hui jeudi à versailles à
l'occasion de la journée internationale
des droits des femmes trois femmes
justement sont venus témoigner lors de
la jdc qui a réuni 150 jeunes
une directrice des services de grève
judiciaire une ingénieur militaire
d'infrastructures et une chargée
d'études avec les territoires à la
direction des patrimoines de la mémoire
et des archives
elles sont venues parler de la
féminisation du ministère de la défense
et de la fonction publique
propos recueillis sur place par patrick
jacques de dixmude et quentin le frère
on a une un taux de féminisation qui ne
cesse d'augmenter au sein des ministères
des armées et donc parler parler
des femmes au sein des armées et des
métiers des possibilités qu'elles ont de
carrière m'a semblé important
l'armée française compte soixante mille
femmes en son sein elles sont elles sont
divisées en deux groupes
des militaires qui sont au nombre de 16
%
et puis 38 % de personnel civil féminin
donc voilà et ce qui fait de nous ben on
est en quatrième place juste derrière
les etats-unis pour le taux de
féminisation de désarmer un village
dédié aux femmes c'est le principe de
rituels santé organisée par
l'association yvelinoise hf prévention
et le laboratoire msd france il s'est
installé jusqu'à demain vendredi sur le
parvis du quartier de la défense cet
espace éphémère de 300 m² rassemble des
associations et sociétés spécialisées
dans le domaine de la santé est nicolas
landry a s'est rendu sur place pour
l'inauguration un utérus géant au coeur
du village rituel santé un outil
pédagogique pour sensibiliser les femmes
à certains risques notamment le cancer
du col de l'utérus cette pathologie
touche près de 3000 personnes en france
par an malgré les mesures de prévention
de cette maladie on le prévient de deux
manières la première c'est ce qu'on
appelle la prévention primaire c'est à
dire éviter qu'il y ait des lésions les
lésions sont liées à un virus qui est le
papillomavirus et il y à des vaccins
contre le papillomavirus donc qu'ils
évitent cette infection
et il y à la prévention secondaire qui
est lié au dépistage par frottis
réguliers nous sommes là pour parler de
tous les cancers
gynécologique et de la prévention de ce
que les femmes d'affaires en amont ne
pas se négliger et régulièrement faire
des examens faire des contrôles ces
préventions s'inscrivent dans le cadre
du village éphémère rituel une dizaine
d'associations et de professionnels de
la santé avec comme marraine de
l'opération sandrine quétier
un événement organisé par hachette
prévention et le laboratoire msd dans le
cadre de la journée internationale des
droits des femmes
eh bien on va replacer la santé au coeur
des préoccupations des femmes les droits
des femmes c'est super important leur
santé aussi et c'est important qu'elles
prennent soin d'elle c'est pour ça que
le village rituel effectivement s'est
mis à exister en france d'après un
sondage ipsos 55% des femmes actives
estime avoir un état de forme inférieur
à 7 sur 10 et pour être complet sur la
journée internationale des droits des
femmes une table ronde se tient ce soir
à partir de 18h30 à la salle du prisme à
elancourt elle concerne les corps
sportif au féminin c'est à dire la
question à l'adulte du sport au féminin
il sera notamment soulevé la question de
la médiatisation du sport et l ac est
elle assez comparable finalement face à
la médiatisation du sport masculin c'est
l'une des questions qui sera posée ce
soir les yvelines terre bénie du
scoutisme c'est là une affiché par nos
confrères de l'hebdomadaire toutes les
nouvelles le 14 février dernier vous
avez d'ailleurs pouvoir voir cette une
peut-être dans un instant voilà elle
s'affiche à l'écran un dossier spécial
sur le sujet avait été consacré dans cet
hebdomadaire le département elle compte
plus de 15000 scout c'est le premier en
france tous mouvements confondus il y en
a trois principaux dans l'hexagone les
scouts et guides de france les guides et
scouts d'europe troisième mouvement
c'est les scouts unitaires de france
bonsoir xavier laroche
bonsoir vous êtes membre national du
comme membre du conseil national des
scouts unitaires de france ancien chef
de groupe dans les îles
il y en a 26 dans le département pour
votre mouvement n'aura l'occasion d'en
parler dans un instant déjà quelques
mots de présentation peut-être déjà sur
l'histoire du du scoutisme s'était créé
il ya plus de cent ans par un anglais
qui s'appelait robert baden powell
absolument il a créé le scoutisme en
1907 le scoutisme a été importé en
france en 1911
et puis ça a été adapté au catholicisme
en 1920 aujourd'hui en france il ya à
peu près 170 mille scouts en france et
comment et quand finalement ce mouvement
est il arrivé en france alors il a
démarré en donc au début du 20e siècle
en 1907 il a été créé par des départs en
fait qui ont souhaité que leurs enfants
fassent du scoutisme et puis petit à
petit ça s'est largement développée
aujourd'hui il ya neuf mouvements
principaux qui sont enfin neuf
mouvements qui sont reconnus par le
ministère chargé de la jeunesse d'accord
et il est trois principaux mouvements
comme vous l'avez indiqué sur des
mouvements catholiques les scouts
unitaires de france sont le troisième
mouvement nous sommes 28 mille adhérents
chez les scouts unitaires de france
alors pour les valeurs du scoutisme si
on présente ses valeurs il ya l'idée
derrière d'un projet éducatif une
éducation qui se fait par le jeu alors
il est absolument en fait les objectifs
du scoutisme c'est de compléter en fait
l'éducation qui est reçu par les enfants
dans leur d'abord dans le par les
parents donnés par leurs parents et dans
leurs familles ensuite à l'école qui
leur apporte aussi une éducation et puis
le troisième dimension on va dire ça
peut être le scoutisme ça va c'est le
scoutisme pour ceux qui le souhaitent et
l'objectif c'est de créer en fait de
faire en sorte que les jeunes et les
enfants progressent et deviennent des
adultes actifs au rugby
responsables qui sont capables de
prendre des engagements qu'ils
deviennent des citoyens qui sont qui
veulent préserver en fait
l'environnement et qui sont respecte les
autres et puis la dimension spécifique
en tout cas chez les mouvements
catholiques chez les scouts unitaires de
france c'est que ça leur permet aussi
d'approfondir leur foi et leur vie
chrétienne
alors il ya une notion aussi très
importante dans le scoutisme c'est la
notion de grand frère voilà alors
l'organisation par ce qu'on appelle des
patrouilles en fait où on a des jeunes
de 12 à 17 ans permet en fait au plus
est né au plus grand de s'occuper des
plus petits les plus petits voient dans
ces grands des exemples à partir de quel
âge on peut devenir scouts alors on peut
commencer les plus jeunes ce sont les
louveteaux et jeannettes chez les filles
ça commence à 8 ans d'accord et jusqu'à
12 ans et à partir de 12 ans jusqu'à 17
ans donc ce sont soit des éclaireurs
chez les garçons soient des guides chez
les filles et la nature c'est le terrain
de jeu des scouts alors les scouts aime
la nature
les scouts aime la nature les scouts
pratique le scoutisme dans la nature et
cherche à être bien respectueux comme je
l'aï indiqué tout à l'heure de
l'environnement
alors vous en avait parlé il ya
plusieurs courants dans le scoutisme des
scouts
il ya les scouts unitaires de france 1
qui sont catholiques vous l'avez dit
comme les deux autres grands mouvements
scouts
il ya aussi des mouvements protestants
israélite et même laïque
qu'est ce qui fait finalement la
différence pour les scouts unitaires de
france quelle est la particularité des
scouts unitaires de france je crois que
sur les objectifs du scoutisme tous les
mouvements se rejoignent après c'est sur
la pédagogie et la méthode chez les
scouts unitaires de france nous avons
privilégié de d'avoir des unités qui
sont homos qui sont d'une part les
petits de 8 à 12 ans ensuite on a les
plus jeunes qui plus grands qui ont de
12 à 17 ans et puis après il ya les
aînés qui vont de 17 à 20 ans donc les
jeunes sont regroupés dans ses
différentes unités et nous gardons
une pédagogie différente pour les
garçons et pour les filles voulaient
lyon rentre jeunes chez les scouts est
ce qu'on y reste à vie on reste un scout
à lui bah je sais pas on peut le devenir
tardivement c'était mon cas quand suis
devenu chef de groupe parce qu'il n'y
avait jamais fait de scoutisme
auparavant alors pour clôturer cet
entretien un focus plus particulier sur
le département des yvelines on l'a dit
tout à l'heure 26 groupes de scouts
unitaires de france dans le département
ça représente environ 4000 personnes
c'est le deuxième département en terme
d'effectif derrière paris et si vous
êtes d'accord avec le titre que dont je
parlais tout à l'heure des nouvelles de
versailles est-ce que les yvelines c'est
une terre bénie du scoutisme pense qu'il
ya deux raisons à ça la première c'est
que il ya des parents l'origine de
création des groupes il ya des parents
qui souhaitent que leurs enfants fassent
du scoutisme
il est probable que eux mêmes ont
pratiqué le scoutisme auparavant il
souhaite aussi confié leurs enfants aux
à des mouvements scouts notamment aux
scouts unitaires de france
et puis il ya un autre élément qui est
la configuration du département où il ya
des villes relativement importante avec
une concentration de jeunes de familles
et puis il ya des espaces de forêt c'est
un département aussi rural
donc cet aspect rural permet au
scoutisme ou de bien se développer dans
les yvelines implantation dans les
yvelines est ce que à l'échelle de
l'europe la france est un pays aussi du
scoutisme
je pense que vous savez dans le monde on
cite des chiffres assez différent mais
on est autour de 30 millions de scouts
dans le monde d'accord en france il ya
170 mille donc ça reste important en
tout cas c'est un mouvement qui se
développe pour nous la croissance est de
l'ordre de 3% par an de l'augmentation
du nombre d'adhérents 26 groupes dans
les yvelines ce sera ma dernière
question est ce que il ya des échanges
entre ces groupes à l'intérieur du
département peut-être aussi à
l'intérieur la france c'est différent
des chances qui se met en place entre
alors il ya des échanges de bonnes
pratiques des échanges de
bon de bonnes adresses pour camper là
donc oui ça fonctionne bien les échanges
entre les chefs de groupe
merci à xavier laroche d'avoir été avec
nous merci membres du conseil national
des scouts unitaires de france ancien à
chef de groupe dont les yvelines et pour
plus d'informations sur les scouts
unitaires de france
vous pouvez vous rendre sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
et début 2019 le centre commercial
vélizy 2 finira samu il accueillera un
nouveau complexe cinématographique et un
espace dédié à la restauration et les
travaux d'extension ont débuté il ya
tout juste un an un objectif pour ce
projet de concept architectural
particulier augmenter le nombre de
visiteurs sujet d'aurélie rose et
michael et demi d'euros dans un an ce
vaste chantier ressemblera à cela un
nouveau complexe de vingt mille mètres
carrés adossé au centre commercial
vélizy 2 montant de l'investissement 130
millions d'euros
l'idée larchitecture c'est qu'on révèle
le programme intérieur depuis
l'extérieur donc on a on identifiera le
cinéma parce que le cinéma bénéficiera
de cette espèce de grande bulle en verre
en fait rétro éclairé la nuit qui qui
qui symbolisera en fait de façon
iconique le cinéma avec ses 18 salles et
ses 3800 fauteuil il deviendra le plus
grand cinéma du sud ouest parisien
objectif pour la direction de vélizy 2
qu'il se place dans le top 10 des
cinémas français en terme de
fréquentation par rapport à aujourd'hui
un million de visiteurs supplémentaires
est attendu au cinéma qui va offrir aux
spectateurs une technologie avec des
grands volumes d écran xxl qui
permettront vraiment de profiter de
toute la programmation peut proposer le
groupe ugc donc des films en vod si
mauvais en vf de l'opéra qui pourrait
diffuser des retransmissions dont une
programmation beaucoup plus vagues
beaucoup plus riche que ce qu'on peut
proposer actuellement la direction
souhaite avant tout apporter une
dimension loisirs au centre commercial
existant
un espace détente avec 19 restaurants et
kiosques vient compléter ce projet on va
avoir une grande entrée est directement
on va arriver sur une place principale
avec tous ces restaurants qui vont créer
une atmosphère très cosy et le but c'est
vraiment qu'on vienne à vélizy 2 pas que
pour le shopping en 2017 le centre
commercial vélizy 2 a accueilli 14 7
millions de
visiteurs un chiffre que la direction
espère bien augmenter avec cette
extension patrimoine c'est un lieu peu
connu mais non moins a chargé d'histoire
à deux pas du palais du roi de rome à
rambouillet le pavillon du verger va
être rénové un chantier qui va concerner
notamment les médaillons de l'édifice
datant du xviiie siècle les précisions
de mélanie poker c'est dans cette pièce
délabré du pavillon du verger que se
cachent les médaillons un décor date et
2770 dissimulée sous plusieurs couches
de peinture qui en cache la finesse le
but de la restauration c'est d'abord de
préserver le monument qui se trouve très
dégradé et le décor en danger puisque il
ya beaucoup d'infiltrations donc ce
décor qui est essentiellement en plâtre
est complètement solidaire du monument
le travail des restaurateurs de monsieur
madame données donati va d'abord
consister à dégager les multiples
couches de repeint pour retrouver les
couleurs d'origine donc ils ont fait
d'eux des sondages
situé à quelques mètres seulement du
palais du roi de rome le pavillon du
verger est acheté en 1727 par le comte
de toulouse
il appartient à la ville de rambouillet
depuis 1989
on est en train de finaliser le projet
de restauration les appels d'offres aux
entreprises devrait être lancé d'ici
l'été pour un début de chantier à
l'automne 2010 huit ans donc c'est un
projet en fait qui va durer à peu près
un an et demi pour imaginer une
inauguration en 2020 d'un montant de 600
mille euros le chantier sera
subventionné à hauteur de 70% par la
drac notamment il se visitera sur
réservation et pour découvrir le projet
de restauration une conférence est
organisée à la long terme de rambouillet
le samedi 10 mars à 16 heures en
présence de l'architecte autre
conférence de présentation ce samedi
celle du deuxième festival de cinéma des
alternatives on est à tout juste un mois
de l'événement qui se tiendra du 5 au 8
avril au cinéma le roxane à versailles
pour en parler avec mon plateau vanessa
van cutsem bonsoir et vous êtes membre
de l'équipe organisatrice de cet
événement impulse est on le rappelle par
l'association des colibris de versailles
avant d'en parler je vous propose de
regarder la bande annonce de cet
événement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le deuxième festival de cinéma des
alternatives du 5 au 8 avril au cinéma
le roxane à versailles alors quatre
jours de festival sur ce festival quatre
jours de festival donc on y parlera
d'énergie d'agriculture d'habitat de
déchets de transport ou encore
d'éducation plein de thématiques on va
peut-être avoir l'occasion d'en parler
tout à l'heure bien d'autres sujets
encore
finalement quel est l'objectif de ce
festival le cinéma
l'objectif donc c'est la deuxième
édition de ce festival qui avait connu
un certain succès l'année dernière est
l'objectif de ce festival pour nous
c'est de présenter des initiatives
qu'ils soient plutôt local est positive
en tout cas de l'au delà de sensibiliser
les spectateurs c'est un manque de leur
proposer des solutions qui sont
accessibles à tout à chacun
donc c'est un festival impulsée par
l'association des colibris de versailles
dont vous faites partie qui sont les
colibris l'association des colis vitré
cei c'est une association d'habitants
fait de versailles et de communes
limitrophes qui s'inspirent du mouvement
national tout en étant une association
indépendante donc tels quels sont les
finalement les missions de l'association
aria énormément de projets qui sont
impulsées par les colibris qui sont
recensées de manière un peu plus poussée
sur le site qui recense toutes les
activités
mais les activer les activités
principales sont surtout les jardins
partagés la ressourcerie des initiatives
et répare café
plus des projections aussi sont
régulières du coup j'essaie roxane une
fois par mois
donc ils sont un peu aussi à
l'initiative de ce festival un peu plus
conséquents qui du coup diffuse 12 films
en quatre jours alors une première
édition du festival s'est tenu l'an
passé à versailles vous en avez dit au
bout tout à l'heure ça a été une
réussite cette première édition ça a été
une réussite on a compté environ 1400
entrez donc ce qui est vraiment bien
beaucoup de retours positifs beaucoup de
rencontres beaucoup partagent donc c'est
assez assez naturellement qu'on a pas
envie de refaire une seconde édition
ça a été aussi demandé du made in par le
public mais tout à fait vraiment surtout
pour le public mais si alors douze films
qui seront en projection cette année
dans le cadre de ce festival de cinéma
des alternatives ça débutera le 5 avril
par la projection de l'urgence de
ralentir un film réalisé par philippe
borrel
donc c'est un film qui présente un
certain nombre d'initiatives citoyennes
donc plutôt général en fait sur une
thématique biodiversité et donc cette
première séance en fait elle est
gratuite sur inscription donc le public
peut s'inscrire via le site des colibris
d'accord ou via la page facebook de
l'événement du festival
on va peut-être voir s'afficher en bas
de l'écran alors sera abordé également
dans le festival la thématique de la
mobilité douce avec le film bike versus
cars un film de frédéric berthe n tout à
fait un film
du coup suédois sur vraiment des
mouvements militants
pour c'est toujours citoyens pour
trouver une vraie place du vélo en fait
dans les grandes villes
et c'est principalement la forme de
mobilité qui est abordé dans le film
mais le de la thématique plus générale
de la mobilité douce et bien sûr en
filigrane dans le film on aborde aussi
différentes simatic donc l'alimentation
avec un film sur le véganisme qui
s'appelle en pâtit dead hand soja alors
je sais pas si je prononce bien c'était
un espagnol
donc c'est l'aide on t'aura prononce
bien donc oui un film qui parle de
légalisme voilà et de notre relation aux
animaux
un film quand même très positif et enfin
plutôt sympathique et drôle on va dire
sans images choquantes ou qui vraiment
questionne notre notre rapport à
l'animal dont la vie de tous les jours
et notamment aussi qui questionne les
abus de l'utilisation des animaux dans
notre vie quotidienne ou une autre
thématique et on a entendu parler
beaucoup pendant la dernière campagne
présidentielle la démocratie
participative qu'on peut voir fleurir
oueds et des projets de de démocratie
participative dans certaines communes
c'est un sujet qui est traité dans le
film des clics et des clics de
conscience par dont un réalisé par
jonathan athias et alexandre lumbroso
tout à fait donc c'est un film qui est
assez connu du public puisqu'il est
sorti déjà déjà il ya deux ans on a
beaucoup parlé autour du projet de loi
sur les semences et c'est vraiment
un phénomène de sites ou de
participation est citoyenne sur un
projet de loi donc là on va faire des
pétitions qui peuvent être signés sur
internet m'a parlé de trois thématiques
y en aura bien d'autres qui seront
abordés ici
un film sur l'éducation la communication
bienveillante un film
sur le printemps citoyens aussi il ya
aussi des animations folle aussi tout au
long du festival autour cgc projection
voilà des animations qui sont composés
donc tout au long des trois jours entre
les séances donc en fait chaque jour
nous avons trois séances donc une à
14h01 à 17 heures et une à 20h donc pas
mal
bien sûr on aura des invités pour des
débats mouvant à la suite de la plupart
victimes des projections et des
discussions après le taf ont donc
jusqu'au des questions pratiques le
tarif de l'entrée c est vous pouvez
retrouver toutes les informations sur la
page facebook qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci vanessa beaucoup de celle
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle
membres de l'organisation du 2e festival
de cinéma des alternatives ça se tient à
versailles du 5 au 8 avril au cinéma le
roxane et pour plus d'informations je
vous invite encore une nouvelle fois à
vous rendre sur la page qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran culture toujours avant de
se quitter le printemps des poètes
continue aujourd'hui les poètes
justement ont sillonné l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines pour
déclamer poèmes et récits et comme
chaque année ils se sont associés au
réseau stibus reportage de camille
lambert et mélanie poquet
ils sont là en catimini mais pas pour
longtemps parmi les passagers de ce bus
en direction des l'encours des poètes
l'herbe dit vous ne fait aucun bruit
pour pousser l'enfant pour grandir le
temps pour passer l la brigade colomban
lancé l'embuscade poétique
nous on est plus spécialisé pour aller
aux gens à la personne lors faire ce
petit cadeau du poème qu'on leur donne à
titre personnel avec une carte où ils
peuvent re lire des d'autres poèmes des
mots susurrer à l'oreille des passagers
du réseau stibus c'est la troisième
année que les artistes investissent les
transports en commun pour le printemps
des poètes le projet il s'agit de mettre
la poésie accessible à toutes et à tous
et un des endroits les plus
emblématiques c'est bien les transports
publics donc on travaille avec ski bus
et donc on propose aux voyageurs
l'écoutent de poèmes ou donnés par des
compagnies théâtrales dont contrebande
d'elancourt et les profs d'histoire de
paris une quinzaine de comédiens a
sillonné les limes saint-quentinoise
pour ensoleiller cette journée grisâtre
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal sept
centièmes de la saison est à revoir bien
sûr sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv
soixante dix huit belle soirée à tous
[Musique]